[Music]
request to stay clear from our passage
in accordance with the cision regulation
over off the coast of the Philippines
clashes with China have become a common
occurrence which Philippine officials
call um David versus golad situation the
external security environment is
becoming more complex it is becoming
more unpredictable the rising tensions
between the two countries have major
implications for the United States and
have opened the door for a greater US
military Pres in the Philippines we're a
mutual defense treaty partner and we
will come to the aid of the Philippines
if they're attacked it's as simple as
that here's what's happening in the
Philippines and why the country is
becoming increasingly important to
Global superpowers big players in the
Pacific and smaller Neighbors in the
South China Sea first let's talk
superpowers the Philippines is part of
an arc of us allies and partners that
Washington is leaning on for help
countering China to its West is the
South China Sea a massive global
Shipping Lane that that Beijing claims
almost all of to the north is the
Democratic island of Taiwan a key
Western trading partner that China has
threatened to take by force to learn
more about the Philippines growing
strategic importance we traveled there
in April during the largest ever
exercises between the US and Philippine
militaries Stinger launch
coming
Stingers Patriots and
himars some of America's most powerful
ful weapons engaged in a target practice
over the South China Sea a body of water
that China has steadily moved to
control up north troops conducted air
assaults from a Navy ship flying to
Islands just 100 miles from Taiwan the
world's leading producer of advanced
semiconductors which China has
threatened to take by force we don't
want a war with China nobody wants that
that said that doesn't distract me from
doing my job that's my job is the US
prepared to fight absolutely and that's
what we're doing
here the Philippines has moved closer to
the United States under its new
president Ferdinand Marcos JR this is
the first time a president has actually
attended a major live fire event so this
year was different yes this year was
significantly different the shift comes
after marcos's predecessor Rodrigo
duterte tried to steer the country
closer to Beijing I want to be a friend
to China despite his efforts China
didn't back off of its claims near the
Philippine Coast and has only ramped up
its show of force How concerned are you
with the continued provocation from
China as concerned as you could possibly
be for help defending its sovereignty
Manila struck a major base deal with
Washington this year increasing us
access to Philippine military bases
across the country from 5 to 9 and
officials say they are continuing a
dialogue about adding even more the
developments have angered officials in
Beijing who have said that China opposes
the wanting expansion of military
alliances and have accused the US of
trying to contain China China's Embassy
in Manila didn't respond to requests for
comment for this story both China and
the US are major trading partners to the
Philippines but this year Manila and
Washington have taken steps to boost
economic cooperation with the US
pledging to invest in everything from 5G
networks to critical mineral production
throughout the country these countries
have to maintain their sovereignty it's
important to them it's important to us
we want to help them do it the
Philippines is also moving closer to us
allies in the Pacific like Australia
Japan and South
Korea some of those countries have also
trained alongside Filipino troops and
with Marcos in charge their leaders have
made moves to improve ties with Manila
this elevation is an important symbol of
the strength of our relationship and our
shared commitment to do more
together these Pacific Powers also
alarmed by China's growing
militarization of the region recognize
that the Philippines is on the front
lines in the effort to push back on
Beijing China's distorting the story to
fit its own ends China has made
expansive Maritime claims using this n-h
line which is believed to be based on
maps used by the Republic of China in
1947 within those lines Beijing has
seized control of reefs and islands and
turned them into military outposts to
maintain control Chinese ships routinely
harass Philippine vessels with water
cannons signs and military grade
lasers China's actions have angered much
of the population and under Marcos the
Philippines has been pushing back the
Coast Guard has adopted a new strategy
of publicizing encounters with Chinese
ships and calling out Beijing for not
abiding by an international ruling that
invalidated China's n-h line claims it
just goes to show that the Chinese have
always been um ignoring the
international law Beijing has ignored
the international ruling and has said
that its Maneuvers are legal and
Justified now Pacific powers like
Australia and Japan are planning to
conduct joint patrols with the
Philippines to up the pressure on
Beijing and keep the waters that are
vital to their economies and National
Security open and free to have friends
like you and partners like you and that
is uh very gratifying and encourages us
to continue uh down that path but the
Philippines itself is still facing major
challenges when it comes to protecting
its borders and helping people hello yes
it work the economy has been growing
with the World Bank forecasting 6%
growth in 2023 and while the country has
been blessed with a wealth of natural
resources and a young and growing
population millions of people leave to
work abroad more than 15% of the
population lives in poverty and Rising
prices have hit hard inflation for Rice
the country's number one food staple
surged to 8.7% this summer prompting the
government to impose pre caps and fish
stocks another food staple have been
declining the country is also plagued by
its small number of military assets its
frail power grids and its congested
roads it would be faster if you walked
no start this way Mom it's also racing
to explore new sources of energy since
its main gas field malampaya is expected
to run out within a decade Reed Bank a
site seen as key to unlocking more
energy is at the center of a dispute
with China for the Filipino people it's
very simple that is ours Victor dindo
manit runs polling on issues like
China's actions in the South China Sea
he says a lot of these challenges help
illustrate why the Filipino people
support the country moving closer to the
United States and its allies there are a
lot of challenges and people will say
and I agree with them we lost time but
for me it's not too late we are now
moving towards to work with other
countries and that's what we all need
here but these countries are ready to
work with the
Philippines
for